federal contractors are working to nade
versions of a southern border wall this
morning a wall dividing the u.s. and
Mexico was one of President Trump's main
campaign promises the eight prototypes
are being built in a remote area of San
Diego California in effect builders are
auditioning for the full government
contract it has not been funded yet
material is in San Diego along the two
existing walls that separate Southern
California from Mexico
Mireya good morning well good morning
those prototypes will be built about two
miles east of the San Diego Tijuana
border and as you can see right behind
me there are already a Zabar border wall
at a border fence here still with our
cameras rolling yesterday border patrol
was getting ready to talk to the media
when a man from Chiapas Mexico jumped
over the fence ran right behind them and
into the United States a few miles from
where construction has begun on the
border wall prototypes this man entered
the US illegally Tuesday and was
arrested by Border Patrol agents i sat
with Juan Gomez a young father from
Chiapas Mexico que quieres hacer aqui en
estados unidos
gomez told me he came here for work and
for a better future
acting Border Patrol sector chief Royale
says his agents need more help how
important is it for them to have
something that is better than what is
already in place having worked for 29
years along the border it has been a
constant evolution we were arresting
over half a million people
illegal entrants a year by the way the
wall is happening folks okay in Alabama
last week President Trump said the new
wall will be done in six to seven months
few people agree with that and what he
wants aesthetically is at odds with
initial instructions to contractors so
you need to have a great wall but it has
to be has to be see-through and we're
looking at different samples already of
see through walls and I think all stuff
to be honest with you a see-through wall
would look better
a prototypes will be built each between
18 and 30 feet high and stretching 30
feet long four of them using concrete
and four built with alternate materials
contractors can work 24 hours a day for
30 days to build their version of the
wall acting chief Yael told reporters in
the end the government's choice may be a
combination of designs these prototypes
will only serve to get the president to
send another tweet and we'll do it won't
do a single thing to protect our
security along the border Christian
Ramirez represents more than 60 groups
that oppose the wall this is nothing
else than political theater at the
expense of taxpayers the prototypes will
cost about five hundred thousand dollars
apiece the president has asked for 1.6
billion dollars to fund this new border
wall project this alone so far Congress
has not approved that dollar amount let
alone the tens of billions of dollars it
will take to build a full version of the
president's border security plan Gayle
Maria thank you very much